at the National Center for
supercomputing applications I've been
able to work as an artist with
scientists and take data and make the
invisible visible
her team works with real astronomical
data these this is not CGI this is not
made-up stuff Tony really wanted us to
take her and the audience on these
flights through the Milky Way galaxy and
toward Earth this is the cinematic
presentation of scientific data we use
catalogues of observe telescope data
embedded in our Milky Way model and
we're able to take the audience where
cameras can't go
it's mesmerizing we take billions of
numbers that come out of big computers
we take those picture elements pixels
and we can create a virtual reality
we've compiled catalogs of data on
exoplanets and star positions and other
observed data in our Milky Way galaxy
numbers and frequencies from things like
telescopes and we bring them all
together in a scene every star in the
Milky Way is in there and they all have
numbers and names and you can move from
one point in space through to
destination that you choose
Tony Myers and the IMAX team really want
to get the science right and yet they
also wanted to to be beautiful and
inspirational emotional and we love
achieving that same goal
today more than ever before we're seeing
their kind of Renaissance of artists and
scientists working together to bring the
visual to people and the accuracy of
science to be embedded in that visual
you